ROBERT MUELLER'S TESTIMONY
TURNING OUT TO BE AN ABSOLUTE
DISASTER FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND
THE MEDIA.
THEY ALL TOLD US HE WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE THE GUY WHO WAS GOING TO
TAKE DOWN THE PRESIDENT AND BE
THE SAVIOR OF THE REPUBLIC.
AFTER HIS LACKLUSTER
PERFORMANCE, DEMOCRATS AND THE
MEDIA ARE THROWING MUELLER UNDER
THE BUS, INCLUDING FILMMAKER
MICHAEL MOORE WHO TWEETED "A
FRAIL OLD MAN UNABLE TO REMEMBER
THINGS, STUMBLING, REFUSING TO
ANSWER BASIC QUESTIONS.
I SET IT IN 2017 AND MUELLER
CONFIRMED IT TODAY.
ALL YOU PUNDITS AND MODERATES
AND BLAME DEMS WHO TOLD THE
PUBLIC TO PUT THEIR FAITH IN THE
ESTEEMED ROBERT MUELLER, SHUT
THE LEAP UP FROM NOW ON."
THEN THERE'S THE LIBERAL MEDIA
EATING THEIR OWN WORDS AFTER
TELLING AMERICA THAT MUELLER'S
TESTIMONY WOULD BE A
GAME CHANGER.
>> DEMOCRATS WHO WERE COUNTING
ON MUELLER TO MOVE THE BALL
FORWARD DIDN'T GET EXACTLY WHAT
THEY WANTED TODAY.
>> THE FORM OF THE ENTIRE
ACCOUNTABILITY MISSION.
ON OPTICS THIS WAS A DISASTER.
>> SHAKY PERFORMANCE.
THAT'S FAIR TO SAY.
>> LOOKED LIKE SOMEBODY WHO HAD
SLOWED A STEP OR TWO.
MAYBE HE WASN'T EVEN IN CONTROL
OF THE ANGRY DEMOCRATS.
>> IT IS SHOCKING IN THE AGE OF
TRUMP TO LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND HOW INEPT THEY SEEM TO
BE TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
>> Jesse: MEANWHILE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND REPUBLICANS
ARE IN FULL MODE AND RIGHTFULLY
SO.
>> THIS WAS A DEVASTATING DAY
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
THE DEMOCRATS HAD NOTHING, AND
NOW THEY HAVE LESS THAN NOTHING.
>> BOB MUELLER WAS TRYING TO
DEFEND THE INDEFENSIBLE.
THE REPORT WAS INCOHERENT AS
WRITTEN AND IT WAS WORSE AS
PLAYED OUT ON LIVE TV.
>> A TRAIN WRECK, UNMITIGATED
DISASTER.
>> EXPECTATIONS ALWAYS OUTPACE
THE REALITY WITH CONGRESSIONAL
HEARINGS BUT THE DISPARITY
YESTERDAY WAS PRETTY STARK.
>> IT'S TIME FOR THE CURTAIN TO
CLOSE ON THE RUSSIA HOAX.
THE CONSPIRACY THEORY IS DEAD.
>> Jesse: MARTHA, ONE OF THE
MAIN REASONS AND THERE'S MANY
REASONS WHY YESTERDAY DIDN'T GO
WELL BUT ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS
IS HE WAS NEVER GOING TO LIVE UP
TO EXPECTATIONS BECAUSE THE
MEDIA HAVE BUILT MUELLER UP TO
BE A GOD.
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             U
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             I
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             P
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             A
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             H
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             B
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             E
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             ,
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             S
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             A
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             E
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             M
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             N
HE WAS IMPEACHABLE             ,
TENACIOUS, THOROUGH.
WE DIDN'T SEE IT AND EVERYONE
WAS DISAPPOINTED.
>> Martha: I DON'T THINK IT'S
A QUESTION OF WHICH SIDE YOU'RE
ON.
IT'S A QUESTION OF WHETHER OR
NOT THIS MOMENT WAS POLITICALLY
SUCCESSFUL OR WHETHER IT WAS
POLITICALLY A FAILURE.
I THINK -- AND THAT'S WHY
THERE'S A BROAD SPREAD AGREEMENT
THAT IT WAS A POLITICAL FAILURE.
I THINK JERRY NADLER LOOKS
TERRIBLE IN THIS SITUATION
BECAUSE HE'S THE ONE WHO PUT HIS
PARTY ON THE LINE AND BANKED ON
IT IN SUCH A BIG WAY.
THINK BACK TO THE MOMENT WHEN
BILL BARR, A WEEK OR SO AGO,
SAID IF MUELLER DECIDES NOT TO
GO, THE DOJ WILL BACK HIM.
THEY DELAYED IT FOR A WEEK, AND
THEN BILL BARR SAYS -- I THINK
IT WAS THE DOOR OPENING, YOU CAN
TAKE A PASS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS.
THERE WAS KNOWLEDGE BEHIND THE
SCENES I THINK ON THE PART OF A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
PERHAPS MR. MUELLER WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO PRESENT THE MATERIAL IN
THE WAY THAT WOULD REALLY WOULD
BE A HOME RUN FOR THEM.
AND THAT THE MATERIAL ITSELF WAS
LACKING.
>> Jesse: IT WASN'T JUST THE
OPTICS.
IT WAS THE SUBSTANCE OF IT
BECAUSE HE'D NEVER BEEN
CROSS-EXAMINED, GREG.
NO ONE HAD BEEN CROSS-EXAMINED.
HE KIND OF WILTED UNDER
CROSS-EXAMINATION.
>> Greg: YEAH, THEY EXPECTED
GERONIMO AND THEY GOT GERITOL.
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY HAS BEEN
NOTHING BUT TERRIBLE CHRISTMAS
MORNINGS FOR THE MEDIA.
THE NIGHT BEFORE, THEY ARE
EXPECTING A PONY UNDER THE
CHRISTMAS TREE AND THEY GET A
BAG OF HAIR, SMELLY HAIR.
THEY EXPECTED MUELLER TO BRING
THE CASE TO LIFE AND HE
EUTHANIZED IT.
IT WAS NOT HIS FAULT.
THEY KNEW THEY WERE BRINGING
SOMEBODY OUT OF RETIREMENT.
LIKE ASKING A FLYING WILL LINDA
AND 95 TO WALK BETWEEN TWO
BUILDINGS.
HE'S BEEN OUT OF PRACTICE.
WHY DOES IT KEEP HAPPENING?
THE DISCONNECT CREATED BY THE
DEMOCRATS' EMOTIONAL BIAS.
THE REALITY IS ALWAYS GOING TO
BE DIFFERENT THAN THE MOVIE
THEY'RE WATCHING.
EVERY DAY FOR THEM IS SUPPOSED
TO BE APOCALYPSE NOW AND IT
ALWAYS IS A BEING HAPPY FEET.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE
IS THEIR IRRATIONAL HYSTERIA
HYSTERIA ABOUT THIS ONE THING
LED TO A SOUL CRUSHING DEFEAT.
I ALMOST BUT NOT REALLY FEEL BAD
FOR THEM.
>> Jesse: YESTERDAY YOU SAID
YOU FELT BAD.
>> Greg: I TEXTED YOU THAT YOU
WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO --
>> Jesse: I THINK YOU SAID IT
ON THE AIR.
>> Martha: YOU'RE NOT A HUMAN
BEING IF YOU DIDN'T FEEL A
LITTLE BIT SORRY.
AMAZING CAREER.
PUT IN A SITUATION HE SHOULD
NEVER HAVE BEEN PUT IN.
I WANT TO SAY BRIAN KILMEADE GOT
LAMBASTED FOR COMING OUT SEVERAL
WEEKS AGO AND SAYING I WONDER
HOW FAMILIAR ROBERT MUELLER
REALLY IS IN THE DETAILS OF THE
REPORT.
HE WAS RAKED OVER THE CALLS.
HE LOOKED PRETTY SMART YESTERDA
YESTERDAY.
>> Jesse: WILL WAIT A MINUTE,
KILMEADE?
>> Jesse: WE DON'T SAY THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS ON THIS SHOW.
>> Martha: YOU'VE GOT TO CALL
IT THE WAY IT IS.
>> Jesse: WE DON'T WANT HIM
GETTING A BIG HEAD BUT WE FOUND
OUT IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
AARON SIBLEY, THE GUY WHO WAS
NEXT TO HIM, HE WAS EFFECTIVELY
RUNNING THIS INVESTIGATION, THEY
SAID.
HE WAS THE CHIEF OF STAFF
RUNNING THE MEETINGS.
HE WAS THE GUY THAT REPRESENTED
THE GUY THAT SET UP CLINTON'S
SECRET EMAIL SERVER AND HELPED
HIM DESTROY BLACKBERRIES WITH A
HAMMER.
NOW WE KNOW THAT CLINTON SET UP
TRUMP AND THAT SHE INVESTIGATED
HIM.
>> Kennedy: THAT'S EXCITING.
>> Jesse: I MEAN IT'S NOT
KILMEADE MATERIAL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Kennedy: MY QUESTION FOR
DEMOCRATS IS WHY WOULDN'T THEY
DO MORE INVESTIGATION?
THEY ARE CONSIDERING THEMSELVES
INVESTIGATORY.
WHY DON'T YOU FIGURE OUT WHO HAS
THE BEST ANSWERS?
WHO HAS THE BEST DEFENSE OF THE
MUELLER REPORT AND WHO CAN FRAME
IT IN SUCH A WAY THAT IT WILL DO
THE MOST POLITICAL DAMAGE?
THERE WERE A LOT OF POLITICAL
PEOPLE ON THE TEAM.
IF IT'S ANDREW WEISSMANN, NOW
YOU CAN'T TROT HIM OUT BEFORE
THE JOINT COMMITTEES.
YOU CANNOT DO THAT.
THE PRESIDENT WAS RIGHT ABOUT
TAKING TOO MANY BITES OF THE
APPLE.
THESE ARE NOT HORSES IN
CENTRAL PARK.
THESE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE SERIOUS
LEGISLATORS AND THEY REALLY
WHIFFED ON THIS ONE AND WE ARE
SO YOU SHOULD BOTH PARTIES
SPINNING LIKE TOPS WHEN THEY GET
BAD NEWS.
IT'S ONE OF THE FEW TIMES WHERE
YOU WILL SEEK CONSENSUS ON ALL
SIDES.
PEOPLE SAYING YEAH, THIS WAS
REALLY HORRIBLE.
>> Jesse: ONE OF THE THEORIES,
JESSICA, IS THAT MUELLER IS A
LAWYER AND HE KNEW HE WAS UNDER
OATH AND HE'S VERY PRECISE AND
HAS A LOT OF INTEGRITY AND HE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE HE HEARD ALL
THE ANSWERS VERY CLEARLY.
THAT'S WHY HE ASKED EVERYBODY TO
REPEAT THEM SO SPECIFICALLY.
>> Jessica: I DON'T THINK
MOCKING BOB MUELLER --
>> Jesse: I'M NOT MOCKING.
I AM REPEATING A THEORY THAT'S
OUT THERE.
>> Jessica: WAS A LOT OF
DISGUSTING THEORIZING GOING ON,
COMMENTING ON HIS HEALTH AND HIS
STATUS AND I FEEL LIKE SO FAR
HERE WE'VE ONLY BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THE OPTICS.
THERE WERE PIECES OF SUBSTANCE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS NOT
EXONERATED OR EXCULPATED.
>> Greg: HE CAN'T BE.
>> Martha: START WITH THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
>> Greg: THERE IS NO COURT
THAT CAN DO THAT.
>> Jessica: SURE, MOVING ONTO
THE NEXT ONE.
>> Greg: YOU ARE 0 FOR 1,
JESSICA.
>> Jesse: YEAH, YOU ARE.
>> Jesse: THE QUESTIONING
UNCOVERED IN THE HEARINGS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND MEMBERS OF
THE TEAM FALSIFIED THEIR
TESTIMONY WHEN THEY MET WITH THE
FBI.
>> Jesse: I DIDN'T HEAR THAT.
CAN YOU SAY THAT AGAIN?
I WILL TAKE THAT QUESTION.
>> Jessica: HERE IS ANOTHER
ONE.
GUIDELINES AND WHAT IT
PROHIBITED HIM FROM DOING.
>> Martha: HE CLARIFIED IT.
>> Jessica: THE BECAUSE OF
OILSEED GUIDELINES THEY WERE NOT
TRYING TO MAKE A DETERMINATION.
NOT THAT HE COULDN'T BE INDICTED
AFTER HE LEAVES OFFICE.
>> Martha: THE GUIDELINES SAY
YOU CAN'T INDICT A SITTING
PRESIDENT.
>> Jessica: IT DOESN'T MEAN HE
HE --
>> Kennedy: THE
NONDETERMINATION OF GUILT.
>> Greg: YOUR FIRST POINT, YOU
CAN'T DECIDE THIS.
>> Jesse: ARE YOU SAYING THAT
IT WENT WELL?
>> Jessica: NO.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS -- I DO THINK
THE INTEL COMMITTEE MEETING
HEARING WENT WELL.
ADAM SCHIFF KNEW EXACTLY WHAT HE
WAS DOING.
THOSE QUESTIONS WERE LOOKING FOR
ONE-WORD ANSWERS.
HE SEEMED CLEAR ON WHERE BOB
MILLER WAS AND WHAT HE NEEDED TO
ACCOMPLISH.
THERE ARE SOUND BITES OF
DEMOCRATS COMING OUT OF THIS
THAT WILL BE IN EVERY 2020 AD
TALKING ABOUT WORKING WITH
RUSSIANS.
PAUL MANAFORT.
>> Martha: I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO WANT TO REMIND